إذا كان هذا الفيديو حقيقيًا، فسيبدو
أنه نظرة نادرة بشكل لا يصدق على
العقوبات الصارمة التي
تفرضها كوريا الشمالية على الأشخاص الذين يتم القبض عليهم وهم
يرتكبون واحدة من أخطر الخطايا التي
يمكن تخيلها وفقًا للنظام الكوري الشمالي
الذي يستهلك
الثقافة الأجنبية وخاصة الثقافة الكورية الجنوبية.
وهو نقيض النزعة
القومية العسكرية الشمالية، لديك
موسيقى البوب ​​الكورية، لديك مسلسلات درامية، كل هذه
البرامج التي نعلم أنه يتم تهريبها
إلى كوريا الشمالية، ونحن نعلم أن
الشعب الكوري الشمالي يشاهدها
بانتظام، وهذا وفقًا لأه العديد من
المنشقين الكوريين الشماليين الذين  قالوا
إن اللمحة الأولى التي حصلوا عليها عن
العالم الخارجي في واحدة من أكثر
الأماكن سرية وتقييدًا ومعزولة على هذا الكوكب كانت مشاهدة
أقراص DVD غير المشروعة في السوق السوداء أو حتى
أشرطة VHS أه التي تعرض هذه الأعمال الدرامية التي
توفر نوعًا من الرؤية الساحرة لـ
الرأسمالية هذا الفيديو أه في
المدرج يبدو أه أن
هناك هذين المراهقين أه يبلغان من العمر 16
عامًا يقفان على خشبة المسرح مع هؤلاء
الأشخاص بالزي العسكري وغيرهم من البالغين
في الجزء الخلفي من المسرح ربما
مديري المدارس المئات ممن يبدو
أنهم طلاب  وسط الحشد وهؤلاء
المراهقين يقفون هناك أه
يقال لهم أنه محكوم عليهم بالسجن
12 سنة مع الأشغال الشاقة بسبب مشاهدة
وتوزيع العشرات من
الأفلام والبرامج التلفزيونية الكورية الجنوبية أه السرد في
الفيديو الذي سأقرأه لكم  اقتباس
منه يقول أنه منذ وقت ليس ببعيد عقدت
محاكمة علنية أه ثم إعطاء
أسماء الفرق والقول أنهم متهمون
بمشاهدة وتوزيع
تسجيلات الأنظمة العميلة هذا ما
تسميه كوريا الشمالية كوريا الجنوبية النظام العميل
دمية في يد الولايات المتحدة هم  يدعي
الفيديو أنهما كانا يبلغان من العمر
16 عامًا فقط في بداية
حياتهما، ولكن تم إغرائهما
بالثقافة الأجنبية مما أدى في النهاية إلى تدمير
مساراتهم المستقبلية، كما قام هذا الفيديو بتسمية
مدرسي غرفهم المنزلية بشكل أساسي مما يفضحهم
أه ويدمر
السمعة وربما يدمر
حياتهم المهنية، وربما حتى حياة
أفراد أسرهم. الآن، أخبر
جهاز المخابرات الوطني في كوريا الجنوبية شبكة
CNN أنه لا يمكنه التحقق مما إذا
كان هذا الفيديو حقيقيًا أم لا، بالطبع
لا تستطيع CNN أيضًا التحقق بشكل مستقل من الفيديو الذي
تم إصداره بواسطة شركة التطوير الجنوبي والشمالي The Soul uh.
المعهد أه هذه
مجموعة تتكون من منشقين كوريين شماليين
لذلك نعلم أن لديهم
اتصالات داخل البلاد يمكنها
تسريب هذا النوع من المواد إليهم،
ونعلم أيضًا أنه في عام 2020
تبنت كوريا الشمالية ما أسموه
أيديولوجية مناهضة رد الفعل  وقانون الثقافة
هذا هو القانون الكوري الشمالي الذي يقوم
بشكل أساسي بتضييق الخناق أثناء انتشار فيروس كورونا
على توزيع مقاطع الفيديو هذه أه
وفرض عقوبات صارمة للغاية مع
الأشغال الشاقة على كميات صغيرة من هذه
المواد المحظورة وحتى الموت في بعض
الحالات سوف ريبلي سي إن إن تايبي